axing a fan-favorite character is a
great way for writers to raise dramatic
stakes and audiences will generally let
them get away with it but sometimes a
character will be headed for the
chopping block only to get a last-minute
reprieve these are the times when
writers almost broke our hearts but then
chose not to and fan favorites who are
originally supposed to die got to live
on Daryl Dixon Walking Dead creator
Frank Darabont wrote the part of Daryl
Dixon especially for Norman Reedus the
character never appears in the comics
the show is based on Daryl was
originally supposed to do a few
appearances and then exit the way most
Walking Dead guests do as zombie food
but a funny thing happened fans loved
the character even though he was
initially totally unlikable
Darabont gave read us a chance to
develop the roll into something special
and over many seasons the character has
become so popular that Robert Kirkman
creator of the still ongoing comic
series has implied he'll eventually
write Darrell into the comics as well no
pictures Jesse Pinkman Breaking Bad
began with the likeable protagonist and
over the course of five seasons turned
him into a strangely likable villain
while the show mostly focused on Walter
White it also dealt with the moral
situations White's family faced and
Walters young partner in crime Jesse
Pinkman played by Aaron Paul originally
Jesse was supposed to meet the Reaper at
the end of season 1 thereby accelerating
Walter White's transformation into a
ruthless drug lord legend has it that
the 2007-2008 Writers strike which
shortens Breaking Bad's first season and
forced plot changes saved Jesse but the
strike really just gave creator Vince
Gilligan time to reconsider Aaron Paul
was just too great to let go it became
pretty clear early on that that would be
a huge colossal mistake to kill off
Jesse Jack Shepherd perhaps nobody
benefited more from the narrative
aimlessness of lost than its star
Matthew Fox who played primary
protagonist Jack Shepherd executive
producer JJ Abrams originally planned to
introduce the clear obvious lead in the
first episode only to sacrifice him by
episodes end Abrams thought this would
keep audiences on their
toes and even cast Michael Keaton in the
role who was thrilled with the idea of
getting a network TV role without having
to commit to the entire series Keaton
eventually backed out when showrunners
decided that the character would be kept
alive as Keaton explained to Access
Hollywood an hour show every week I've
got stuff to do I've got a life to lead
and when I fish
[Music]
han Solo Harrison Ford has long seemed
ambivalent toward his most famous role
Star Wars iconic Han Solo it seems like
a minor miracle that Solo survived as
long as he did with Ford ruthlessly
pushing for his own character's demise
during the original series Solo was left
ambiguously frozen at the end of the
Empire Strikes Back specifically because
nobody knew whether Ford would come back
for a third installment when he was
coaxed to return he lobbied George Lucas
unsuccessfully for solos noble sacrifice
in Return of the Jedi
George didn't think there was any future
in dead han toys of course spoiler alert
the character finally did meet his end
in the force awakens and if any of the
many fan theories are correct it may
have been just the noble sacrifice that
Ford always wanted Ellen Ripley 1979's
alien was one of the first genre films
to feature a strong female lead but in
production Sigourney Weaver's Ellen
Ripley wasn't necessarily central to the
film speaking with Entertainment Weekly
director Ridley Scott revealed his
brutal alternate ending for alien the
alien pulls up the door she Harper lives
and makes no difference
it comes forward and it slams through
her masker rips her head off then the
creature would have called the ground
crew saying I'm signing off in the
captain's voice
fortunately Scott thought better of the
silly idea allowing Ripley to live on to
become an even more badass character in
an even better film this is ripley last
survivor of the Nostromo signing off
nebula in guardians of the galaxy vol 2
nebula played by Karen Gillan revealed
herself to be a more complex character
than the jealousy driven villain she
first appeared to be but she almost
didn't get to stay in the MCU having
been written out at the end of the first
guardians film speaking with screen
crush Gillan said nebula was saved by
rewrites she revealed that her final
scene was never actually shot saying he
never got to that point as soon as we
would get near to it there would be a
noose
Gillan also appeared in Avengers
infinity war and will definitely be in
it's untitled sequel for which she can
thank guardians writer director James
Gunn and his indecisiveness anyways
happy trails
mr. Spock Leonard Nimoy had a famously
complicated relationship with his most
famous character mr. Spock he told the
producers of 1979 Star Trek the motion
picture that he was only going to play
Spock one last time so the character
wasn't even included in the first draft
of the screenplay for Star Trek 2 the
Wrath of Khan
but then screenwriter Jack be so words
had an idea why not give Spock an epic
final scene live long and prosper
Nimoy liked the idea but subsequent
rewrites pushed Spock's final scene
farther and farther back until it was at
the end of the movie
Nimoy approved each draft and loved
sowards writing so much that it made him
want to keep playing Spock which he did
for another 27 years
[Music]